miley now you covered this metallica
song but elton john plays piano on it
and with us right now it's just telling
john to say hello look at you
oh my god hi guys hi miley
hello
how are you doing hey elton
talk to me about metallica for a second
for charity you are putting out a new
album too and this song that you did
with miley appears on both albums it
appears on metallica's album appears on
your new album we're talking about
nothing else matters working with miley
and playing piano to a metallica song
people would naturally think oh elton
john doesn't play a metallica song but
this is this is kind of an elton john
song it's a beautiful
piano piece you do with this song well
it that idea came from andrew walt who
produced the track and played guitar on
it and he said
i want you to start the song and finish
the song because i don't want it to
start with the guitar because that's how
the original record started and listen
this is one of the best songs ever
written to me i mean it's just yes it's
a song that never gets old i'm playing
on this track i just couldn't wait
because the chord structure the melodies
the time
changes it's got it's got drama written
all over it and uh i just thought it was
a great idea to start with piano i have
to say it was a no-brainer playing on
this song it's metallica are probably
you know
the creme de la creme of those kind of
bands of
you can't really define them not a
heavy metal band they're a musical band
their songs aren't just heavy metal
they're beautiful songs and this is such
a melodic song it's just
it's [ __ ] great actually it really is
[ __ ] great and i love the
collaboration between you and miley and
this p the way you you you you
interpreted it through piano is that a
difficult thing to do i think because
the song is so melodic um
you know it's a very beautiful song if
you just take all the guitars and just
sing the song acapella
it's a bit like green sleeves um
it's a beautiful melody so you know when
you've got a beautiful melody to play to
with all the rest going on it's um it's
a juxtaposition of musical instruments
and so i found it really easy i mean
it's a kind of classical song it's like
a classical piece of music what's it
like for you metallica to hear elton
john say these things number one because
i know you guys
i'm probably in your wildest dreams you
never would have thought elton john
would be recording a song of yours i'm
just sitting here we're celebrating our
40th anniversary this year
and um
if if you could have said 40 years ago
when james and i started down to 605 in
[ __ ] norwalk in a garage down there
with our pots pissing if you could say
40 years later that we would still be
functioning that we would be sitting
here one of the greatest stars in the
world next to us with elton on a zoom
and doing your radio show talking about
the accomplishments and what this record
means to so many people that would be
the mind [ __ ] of all mine fox so it's
it's just crazy cool and to sit here to
be able to hear
uh what you just said elton sitting next
to uh james who's been
we've been doing this for 40 years
together the reaction that i could feel
in his body language when you said it
was one of the greatest songs ever
written i know how much that means to
you
and so uh this is just incredible to
hear so thank you this is a great band
one of the greatest bands of all time
it's their 40th anniversary this is a
classic album it's a no-brainer to come
on and pay tribute to people like that
and uh you know it's the nicest thing
about it is
after all this time it's hard to be in a
band you know they're different
personalities these guys are still
together it's like you two i admire that
you know because it's the hardest bloody
thing in the world so kudos to metallica
they are one of the greatest bands of
all time
you